hey guys I'm I'm turning 43 years old
next week and I've been very fascinated
about the people that turn 40 and what
the 40 year mark means for so many a lot
of people reflect a lot of people feel
like that's the year that like oh crap
I'm going on the other side of things
I'm just unbelievably fascinated
Facebook by people's inability to have
perspective on time you know one of the
things that I'm unbelievably passionate
about is that 18 and 22 year olds that
are being told to figure out their life
is just like like the silliest thing in
our culture there's so much defense in
our culture there's so much pressure
there's so much opinions coming from
people who actually subconsciously
misery loves company I didn't have the
fun life I'm gonna suddenly
subconsciously tell you not to have one
but let's focus on 40 40 is not even
half time for the majority of you for
everybody who has too big of a mortgage
too much debt too much responsibility
it's fascinating what the Internet can
do so many people talk about social
media about like what it means in
politics and hate and insecurity and
suicide or you could look at the other
side of it
what it means for all the opportunities
for all of you that got home at 7 p.m.
and the things you can be doing on the
side on the weekends even at the office
depending on how you roll that can start
the next chapter of your life over the
last three years the amount of people
that have emailed me that have taken
advantage of the phone an Instagram
account a Shopify account using eBay
making YouTube videos writing articles
on LinkedIn have completely transformed
their happiness let alone their ability
to switch their job and make a living
for themselves is remarkable if you're
turning 40 or if you're about to turn 40
or if you just turned 40 and you don't
understand that you you are still a baby
you're making a huge huge mistake
change your perspective and change your
life